nous allons nous séparer en chanson
maintenant avec charles trenet il n'y a
pas grand chose à en dire il faut voir
et l'écouter il enchante littéralement
le palais des congrès depuis la semaine
dernière et très certainement jusqu'au 8
novembre prochain on lève donc le rideau
avec michel vial pendante amis je suis
de narbonne 1 18 mai 1911 1913 oui j'ai
76 ans cette année et ma jeunesse est
une maladie mentale affirme charles
trenet et c'est vrai qu'après cinquante
six ans de carrière il demeure à plus
d'un titre un vrai phénomène
un phénomène de librairie actuellement
un phénomène de spectacles encore et
toujours avec cette fantaisie jovial qui
habite chez lui les sujets les plus
graves
sans oublier la prodigieuse mes fils de
la scène à elle seule un défi permanent
autant je crois que ce qui me fait des
bonnes passes et la sincérité ces sacs
alors le l'habillement des dieux des
chansons lui mode tout ça c'est là cela
passe pourquoi rester fidèle en touchant
et s'en va s'engager quand on est seul
debout sur la passerelle
le vent elle outrée monde qui disparaît
quand on regarde les bateaux du son
on prend le temps des choses qu'on
espérait beaucoup de vos chansons quand
on y regarde d'un peu plus près sont
nostalgiques sont mélancoliques
oui c'est vrai mais il ya toujours quand
même un petit côté amusant pour faire
passer je ne travaille pas uniquement
dans la tristesse ou travaillent dans la
sincérité je m'exprime dans la sincérité
mais la tristesse systématique parce que
arrivée devant le public se faire
plaindre c'est quand même une façon
facile d'avoir du succès ne cherchez pas
dans les couloirs de mai château ce
qu'il peut y avoir à l'intérieur mais
piano
vous les trouviez le plus souvent hélas
jenson duran duran d'automne mon seul
ami dorénavant